on the hill today for the giants will be
the right-hander logan webb
looking webb 23 years of age he's a
rookie out of rocklin california
that's what he's done in four starts
2.81 era
really deserves a little bit better than
the 1-1 record that he shows up there
they have not supported him well
defensively
we're about ready to get this game
started to wrap up this three-game
series as marcus simeon gets comfortable
got him and that's how this game gets
started
marcus simeon not that impressed with
lou williams brought it in about one
click to the right
and he wraps the outside corner and gets
himself a strikeout here's chapman who's
hitless in this series got him
as he comes back after falling behind
three and oh
mike fires who he's yet to defeat the
giants and
he's not pitched against the giants of
the athletics so 1-1 on the season last
fish against them with the milwaukee
brewers
there's dickerson left-handed hitter
strikes here's the pitch
it's on the way and dickerson goes after
a high fastball and down he goes
two away and that'll bring up donovan
solano
that's a swing and a miss and that's a
good inning for mike fires with a couple
of strikeout
little walks and he's have them loaded
all right here's davis trying to break
out of it
he's all for his last 15. and here's the
01 pitch to chris and the brachial ball
is bounced a short double play ball
crawford goes to second relay to first
taylor made
he is take the lead but davis bouncing
into a 643 double play
olson scored from third no rbi of course
and it's one nothing is
last of the second i think the rain
falling here at oracle park as brandon
bell leads off against mike fires
left-handed hitter facing the
right-hander and belt rips one down the
right field line
and it is a home run
a line shot right down the right field
wall
down the line at over the wall near the
309 foot marker
to tie the game the happy zone has
always been down and in
and that's exactly where mike fires
through it they set an outside target
and it finds the belt happy zone and
we've got a one more time
2-2 hit towards center in the gap on the
run as dubai
can't get it it's in front of him takes
it on a bounce and tony keeps it going
his fourth hit in the series and a
one-out single for him
brings chapman to the plate runner goes
ball is lined right center field and
that's going to go
a while kemp was on the move so kemp
will get to third
they're going to wave him home and he's
going to make it the ball trickles to
the infield chapman's gonna go all the
way to third and the a's lead two to one
mike fires back to work and now he's got
a lead two one a's brandon crawford
crawford drives it into right center
field and nobody's there
cannon's gonna play it on a hop
crawford's going for two
here's the throw you made it so an
unproductive out by dubon and here's
yostremski crawford goes swinging a
number
and a base hit right where chapman was
crawford's going to score and this game
is tied
and if crawford doesn't go that's an out
i mean right out the end of the bat
and he's looking up he never saw it
because i think he would have been able
to go to second if you'd have seen it
so here's pender
first pitch is hit deep to left field
dickerson's back
and that baby's gone first pitch
that looked good sounded better and long
gone
so pinder comes off the bench batting
for tony kemp
on the first pitch thrown by peralta
pinder delivers a two-run home run
unlocking the game and the a's take a
4-2 lead
so three straight hits off peralta and
here's cannon
cannon hits this one to center and he
hits it well dubon going back still
going back
and it's over his head off the wall
chapman's going to score
see if olson comes in to score and he
will the throw goes to third
cannon with a triple and now it's six to
two
here's piscotty piscotti drills one
high and deep to left and
gone and he might have outdone pinder
so they're saying 454 on that
wow i mean that's up there in big cat
country
but again you look at the location of
this pitch it is on a
t
full extension i don't think he can hit
it better now
about four rows away from clearing the
bleachers the hits just keep on coming
as murphy is going to roll into second
base with a double
hits a high drive to left and this one
is gone
and it's home run derby folks so you
take a look at the high hanging
curveball
and when you hit a ball that's up in the
zone the problem is
with an uppercut it's going to elevate
on contact and that's exactly what this
does
[Applause]
and that one is smoked left center field
nobody's going to get it it's going to
roll all the way to the wall
olson will score chris davis being waved
around third davis is gonna come in to
score
and that's a two-run double and it's
13-2 the a's lead
comes a maintenance game crawford drives
it into center field kenna back still
back
canada at the wall out of here
first of the year for crawford nice and
bad
here's the pitch to robbie that's sent
into right field sinking that's going to
be a base hit it goes right through
rough
rolls all the way to the wall cannas
around second going to third digging
around third he'll come to the plate
and he's going to score and winding up
at third base
is robbie grossman as the a scored their
14th run
queued slowly so davis is going to
ground out he would get an rbi as
grossman comes in the score and it's 15.